what do you think of Israel starting the
ground invasion of Gaza recently on
October 27th the question
is uh should they
continue uh until they have finally
defeated
Hamas uh they're all sorts of reports in
the media including in the Israeli media
that they're not going to be allowed
by the United States to continue this
offensive uh for much more than a few
weeks um the Israelis have been saying
it would it's going to take in in the
best of all possible worlds a number of
months if not a year to finish off Hamas
well it doesn't look like they're going
to have enough time to do that I doubt
whether they can finish off Hamas even
if they're given the time uh I think
they're going to run into Fierce
resistance uh and when they run into
Fierce resistance and large numbers of
Israelis going to die start to die uh
they'll lose their appetite for this and
they the Israelis surely know at this
point in time that even if they finish
off Hamas even if I'm wrong and they're
able to finish off Hamas another group
is going to rise up to uh resist the
occupation the idea that you can use
what Z Yaba insky called The Iron Wall
to beat the Palestinians into submission
is delusional it's just not going to
happen the Palestinians want a state of
their own they don't want to live under
occupation and uh there's no military
solution for Israel here there has to be
a political solution and the only viable
political solution is a two-state
solution I mean you can't go to
democracy you can't go to a situation
where you give the Palestinians equal
rights inside a greater Israel in large
part because there are
now as many Palestinians as there are
Israeli Jews and over time the balance
the demographic balance shifts against
the Israeli Jews and in favor of the
Palestinians in which case you'll end up
with a Palestinian state in Greater
Israel so you know democracy for all
doesn't work uh the Israelis I believe
are quite interested in ethnic cleansing
I think they saw this um uh this recent
set of events as an opportunity to
cleanse Gaza but that's not going to
happen uh the jordanians and the
Egyptians have made it clear that that's
not happening the United States has now
made it clear that that's not happening
and and the Palestinians will not leave
uh they'll die in place uh so uh ethnic
cleansing doesn't work so you're really
left with two Alternatives a two-state
solution or a greater Israel that is
effectively an apartheid state I mean
that's what the occupation has led to
and all sorts of people have been
predicting this for a long long time and
you've now reached the point you know
here in the United States if you say
that Israel is an apartheid state that's
going to get you into all sorts of
trouble but the fact is that Human
Rights Watch Amnesty International and
Bellum which is the leading Israeli
Human Rights group all three of those
institutions or organizations have
issued detailed reports making the case
that Israel is an apartheid state
furthermore if you read the Israeli
media right all sorts of Israelis
including Israeli
leaders refer to Israel as an apartheid
state it's it's not not that unusual to
hear that term used in Israel this is
disastrous for Israel in my opinion and
Steve Walt and I said this by the way
when we wrote the Israel Lobby that
Israel is an aparte state which is
equivalent to Israel as an occupier uh
is not good for Israel uh and that
brings us back to the two-state solution
but as you and I were talking about a
few minutes ago it's hard to see how you
get a two-state
solution and and the end result of this
conversation is utter
despair because the path to a two-state
solution is blocked by the amount of um
hate that's created by civilian deaths
so that plus the fact that the Israeli
government uh is filled with people uh
who have no interest in a two-state
solution they're
ideologically deeply committed to a
greater Israel they want all the land
between the Jordan River River in the
Mediterranean Sea to
be part of a Jewish state they're just
ideologically committed to that and uh
and of course as we were talking about
before with regard to Hamas Hamas wants
everything between the river and the sea
to be a Palestinian State and you know
when you have two sides with those kinds
of views right um um you're in deep
trouble because there's little room for
compromise so what you have to do to get
this to work is you have to convince the
Israelis that it's in their interest to
have a two-state solution and you have
you've already taken care of the PA on
this front the Palestinian Authority but
you've got to convince Hamas that its uh
its maximalist goals are are not going
to work and it's in its interest uh to
follow in the footsteps of Arafat and
accept a two-state solution but uh even
if you do that at this point let's say
that you know there's a lot of
willingness uh intellectually on both
sides to do that the problem is that the
hatred that has been fueled by this
recent C uh this ongoing conflict is so
great that it's just hard to imagine how
you can make a two-state solution work
at this juncture uh that's why I've sort
of taken to saying and I hope I'm wrong
here that you know on the two states
ution uh that that boat has sailed it's
just you know it's no longer possible
well again I believe in leadership and
there's other parties that play here
Other Nations Jordan Saudi Arabia other
other players in the m in the Middle
East that can help that can help through
a normalization of relationships and
these kinds of things there's there's
always hope like you said Slither of
Hope Slither of hope I think human
civilization progresses forward by
taking advantage of the all the slithers
it can get